good morning Hank it's Tuesday I see you
may remember back in the halcyon days of
2007 when I was young and clean-shaven
in the state of Illinois had a budget
our YouTube channel had a resident
mathematician Daniel Biss so Daniel and
I became friends in 2003 just after he
got his PhD from MIT that's a lot of
letters for a numbers guy I'm sorry I
want to apologize to my friends my
family I am deeply ashamed of that joke
but anyway when I met Daniel he was a
math professor at the University of
Chicago only he didn't have to teach any
classes and he also wasn't required to
publish he just sort of had to think
about math Daniel was a good person with
a good life so Hank you can imagine my
surprise when Daniel told me one day
that he no longer wanted to be a
mathematician with the tenure track
professor ship at the University of
Chicago and instead wanted to be a
member of the Illinois State House of
Representatives I mean Daniel is
charming and funny and intelligent but
he did not strike me as a politician
least of all an Illinois politician why
not not generalize about a class of
individuals of course Hank but between
1961 and 2013 most of the people who
served as governor of Illinois were
later imprisoned for corruption not a
couple not some most but Daniel seem to
genuinely believe that government
service was noble and important so back
in 2008 nerdfighteria helped raise money
for his campaign and he lost but then in
2010 he won and then in 2012 he was
elected to the Illinois State Senate
Daniel is a Democrat but he's widely
respected in fact I once met a
Republican member of the Illinois House
who told me Daniel Biss is one of the
smartest people I've ever met only he
didn't say people he said a curse word
Danny was also one of the smartest curse
words I've ever met and he turns out to
be a really effective politician he
passed a hugely important retirement
savings bill in Illinois he passed a law
banning so-called conversion therapy for
LGBT youth
he's also been a big advocate for
privacy especially when it comes to
technology like he passed a bill saying
that police can't use surveillance
drones without a search warrant and I
have to say he's kind of made me believe
in politics again like in an age of
American ideologues he's this practical
and sensible person who genuinely wants
to make people's lives suck less and
refreshingly he doesn't use inflammatory
rhetoric meanwhile the state of Illinois
is careening toward disaster see I know
how to use inflammatory rhetoric
Illinois has over a hundred billion
dollars in pension debt which is unique
in the country it also has a poor credit
rating and it's currently operating
without a budget which is led to if I
may quote Daniel an insane patchwork
incomprehensible nonsense that's not
inflammatory that's factual like one
example of this incomprehensible
nonsense the Illinois State Museum has
closed because of budget cuts but all of
its employees are still going to work in
getting paid neither the Republican
governor nor the Democratic leaders of
the state legislature are at all serious
about the kinds of reform that are
needed to end Illinois decades of fiscal
mismanagement if ever Daniel I would
find out look that's so annoying
alright so Danny was not running for
Comptroller of Illinois if you don't
know what a comptroller is don't worry I
didn't know either until Daniel told me
it's basically like the chief financial
officer for the state and I want Daniel
to win not because he's my friend but
because he's a smart and independent
voice and he's also very good at math
which is a useful skill for a
comptroller but here's the thing
politics in some ways especially local
politics are run by money running for
Comptroller a job I've never heard of
until my friend ran for it costs
millions of dollars so if you want to
know what's wrong with American politics
just remember that campaigns for
Illinois state comptroller cost millions
of dollars so I'm gonna do a fundraiser
for Daniel next month in fact it'll be
my last public appearance before VidCon
the tickets are $40 which I know is a
lot I'm sorry but everybody who goes
will get a copy of an abundance of
katherines signed by both Daniel and me
I hope to see some of you there you can
also donate to Daniel's campaign
directly at Daniel Biss com and
regardless of your political beliefs if
you're lucky enough to live in a country
where your voice matters I would
encourage you to get involved in the
political process one thing I've learned
from Daniel is that good honest people
in politics really can make a difference
hey I'll see you on Friday